je crois pas qu'il y ait de confusion
idéologique au plus haut niveau de
l'état
je pense que c'est fait parfaitement à
dessin c'est à dire que lorsque le
président de la république se trouve en
israël parle aux israéliens de ce qu'il
faudrait qu'il y est un procès
concernant cette affaire il faut rater
quand même c'est quoi la faire c'est une
vieille dame qui a été défenestré d'une
façon absolue un aimant épouvantable par
un homme qui criait allah akbar mais
dont il est avéré semble-t-il en tout
cas pas par les allemands mais nous
avons qu'il était en possession de ses
moyens et voilà qu'il était dément à ce
moment là est donc là la cour d'appel de
paris a rendu une décision au terme de
laquelle elle a dit on ne peut pas le
juger
et c'est dans ce contexte que le
président intervient donc il intervient
à la fois pour donner des gages salaces
dans une réaction de la communauté juive
il intervient justement il intervient
pour donner des gages à entre guillemets
une communauté mais en même temps il
faut quand même rappeler que le
président représente et enfin
institutionnellement est le garant des
institutions et que donc il ne peut pas
à la fois être le garant des
institutions c'est à dire notamment de
la possibilité pour l'institution
judiciaire qui est une fonction
extrêmement importante dans notre état
de droit d'interférer s'il veut
interférer à ce moment là il ne le fait
pas en utilisant sa parole publique
c'est à dire qu'à ce moment là il
demande à sa garde des sceaux de déposer
une proposition de loi qui va venir
modifier les règles du droit qui seront
appliqués par les juges mais il ne fait
pas en plein alors que le que le projet
n'est même pas enfin n'est pas terminé
puisque la cour de cassation n'est pas
saisie et tu as raison il faut vraiment
saluer le communiqué de madame art ans
qui est la présidente de la cour de
cassation et du procureur général de
rappeler à l'exécutif que la justice
doit être indépendante ont cessé c'est
incroyable de le faire mais il le fait
pour des raisons politiques